so we've had some great talks on
evolution so far Nico and saurabh really
laid the lay the foundations quite
nicely and I don't want to tell you I
think I must work more slowly than
everyone else because this is something
I started like seven years ago thinking
about this is most of this project and
and and it's almost published so the
first part of it anyway um and and it's
a collaboration with between my group
and Marston Linehan who's the chief of
urologic oncology at NIH and what makes
one of the things Marston does it's
really unique as he handles the vas a
very large fraction of the families who
have von hippel-lindau syndrome which is
a hereditary syndrome with it with a
deletion or loss of function and VHS and
that's inherited and as a result
patients with von hippel-lindau syndrome
get many kidney cancers clear cell renal
cell carcinomas during their lifetime
and what's been known previously is
these tumors are actually independent
tumors so the the kidney that's been
taken out there you can see lots of
tumors all over the place maybe 10 or 15
independent tumors can be seen there and
we know that and there's been a bunch of
papers showing that because there'll be
different vhl second hits and all these
tumors which is widely believed to be
one of the earliest lesions that allows
these tumors to progress they'll have
different chromosomal copy number
behavior there's been some exome
sequencing of different ones and they
shown shown oxo mutations in common so
there's been a lot of evidence that
these were clonally independent in some
way and it's one of the few humans cases
in which you have a constrained genome
in a constrained environment yet
multiple examples of tumors are rising
in that and so you can sort of start we
can start using tumors from these
patients to think about how strong the
constraints are on tumor evolution given
a fixed genome environment obviously
it's very difficult to to separate those
two because the rising of the same
person but but the effect is really very
powerful and I'll show you some numbers
a little later on what's important
understand here is that we have a pretty
strong belief that the clear cell renal
cell carcinoma CCRCs that arise in von
hippel with
lindale syndrome and those that arise in
sporadic disease are quite similar but
their clinical presentation is quite
different right so what typically
happens is that because it's an
inherited you you actually know who's at
high risk for having von hippel-lindau
syndrome because their parents had it or
one of their parents would have it as
well right and the fraction of de novo
mutations is relatively low compared to
the compared to the contribution from
familial inheritance maybe fifteen or
twenty percent of new cases are sporadic
versus inherited but what you can see is
that the the sporadic case is on the
left they typically don't ignore until
much later in life the people who have
them are typically 50 60 70 s and the
tumors are typically very very large the
one that's pictured there is probably on
the order of 10 centimeters or something
which is a massive tumor it's a much
bigger than a baseball um whereas the
ones that in clear cell in hereditary
clear cell renal cell carcinoma tend to
be small because people are constantly
being imaged and the standard protocol
is to image people to look for new
tumors roughly every six months or so
and and and what they found is that as
soon as they see a tumor they don't go
and operate right away and the reason
for that is because there's too many
tumors these patients would constantly
be in recovery they be having new
surgeries every six months or so and
these are you know relatively invasive
surgeries that we're talking about so
the clinical treatment has actually been
that you follow these patients and if a
tumor gets to three centimeters then you
operate and when you go in and operate
then you take out all the tumors you can
find so at one time you I go in and take
out three or four or five or 10 or 15
independent lesions in one single
surgery and there'll be a range of
different sizes from you know as small
as you can see a half centimeter or
something all the way up to three or
sometimes four centimeters sometimes
even on the regular surveillance they'll
have a tumor that goes very quickly from
one centimeter 25 centimeters and so you
know small fraction of tumors might be
closer to the size you get with sporadic
cases but the but in general these
tumors are typically in the one to three
centimeter range
when they're when they're extracted and
so so the difference in size of the
tumors is really quite remarkable that
might be on the order of a billion cells
versus a tumor that might be on the
order of a trillion cells or something
like that right i mean this that's a lot
obviously three three orders of
magnitude difference in what's going on
so cancer genome atlas has published its
initial study of clear cell renal cell
carcinoma and it it recapitulated
essentially what was known previously
from earlier studies that we have a very
high frequency of mutation von
hippel-lindau vhl gene the very first
bar up there something on the order of
fifty percent of cases have mutation of
the HL another ten or fifteen percent of
cases have methylation of one allele of
vhl and vhl is located on three p21 and
you can see more than ninety percent of
the TCGA cases the top bar and the lower
panel there have loss of chromosome 3
p21 so what we have is a standard
mechanism is loss of one allele of vhl
followed by loss of the chromosome on
the other the other chromosome that
carries a good copy of vhl and the model
typically is mutation followed by loss
of heterozygosity so you can see a
number of other genes PBR m1 and set d 2
and bap1 which are all the same genomic
location as v HL they're all nearby and
and they are expected to be tumor
suppressors as well and so that the loss
of headers are the loss of three p21
reveals these um so so we have you know
on the order of 10 or so genes that are
drivers from TCGA from a pretty
good-sized study 385 cases so that we
probably got most of the reasonably
common drivers down to the few percent
range and and you can see the very some
very stereotypical copy number
aberrations okay so moving on to what we
actually did now um Susie Faye in my
group who was a postdoc who's since
moved on and marstons group identified a
set of six individuals from which 42
tumors were selected
and the tumors are all as far as we
could tell we're all clonally
independent and we had a range of
anywhere between five and 13 independent
tumors per individual Susie selected
them to be sort of an equal mix of
gender smoking history type of von
hippel-lindau mutation on there's
there's a relatively you know sort of
independent of the number of surgeries a
range of folks who were smokers and not
which is a known risk factor a range of
body mass indexes and for for all six we
have blood as a normal control for three
additional tumors we have normal
adjacent kidney that were pretty sure is
pathologically okay um and and you can
see here just in this number of surgery
column that there's a range of surgeries
right so this six year old woman this is
her third surgery on her right kidney
already and she's had a prior she's had
a life seem radical it means her left
kidney has already been taken out right
so there's pretty substantial history
for some of these individuals but for
this male 28 year old male here this is
their first surgery so far and they've
not had one on their left on their left
kidney yet um so Susie would contract
with a limited to whole genome shotgun
sequencing in roughly 40 X which is
obviously a little lower than we'd like
but at the time financially expensive
already and and Susie called mutations
using new checked and a standard
relatively standard pipeline to identify
and so one of the things that was
interesting to see is that there's quite
a strong variation just the absolute
number of mutations per individual right
so tumors from the same individual have
a fairly good spread but there's a quite
a strong bias that pic tumors from the
same individual have have a high
concordance with the yellow individual
sort of the outlier there if you look at
that association with age you can see
that this seems to be mostly a function
of age the the oldest to patients and
the older the patients are them much
more they have far far more mutations
and what she observed here is that we
have a couple outliers in these older
individuals this tumor turns out to
very low curity probably like twenty or
thirty percent tumor and if you've only
got 40 x tumor sequencing you're going
to have a hard time calling mutations
there and so we expect that that the
number of mutations in this and this
tumor is probably quite a lot higher we
just can't observe them and this tumor
actually turns out to be two overlapping
tumors based on re-examination of the
pathology bait at once we say why does
it have so few mutations so the
correlation is quite strong we were
surprised that there wasn't a stronger
correlation with smoking we expected to
see that smoking would contribute to the
mutation burden here it does not appear
to I this is not adjusted by age but i'm
pretty sure that even adjusted by age
would be a very minimal correlation to
smoking history here yeah of course so
so the clinical course is if the tumor
is smaller than than three centimeters
they've never observed a metastasis so
in thousands of individuals right so if
oh it once you've got a four centimeter
tumor there's some small risk of
metastasis like five percent or
something but if the tumors get to take
six centimeters then the risk of my
testicles are very high so the reason
they picked this three centimeter
threshold is basically they've never
lost a patient because of that sometimes
the tumors accelerate very rapidly and
go from one centimeter 25 centimeter
over six months and then they you know
that's that they can't image constantly
to look for these things but but know
that this is because this is a
relatively indolent disease that the the
sort of six-month imaging is is it is a
strategy that works for the vast
majority so you know i think most of
these patients end up I think not dying
of kidney cancer I think most of them
end up dying from eventually they have
to have a kidney transplant and so maybe
they can't get an effective kidney
transplant which I guess you could call
a consequence of the cancer right now
you no longer have a kidney but it's not
quite the same thing as the kick cancer
killed you're right it's just that they
lot to have loss of kidney function so
once they're on transplant they're
obviously transplants are better than
nothing but not as good as having your
own kidney
so just to confirm what we expected to
be true that these tumors are in fact
independent we looked at roughly the
40,000 mutations that we called across
these 40 in Fort sex more that's like a
hundred thousand mutations across these
forty tumors and uh and this is just a
heat map showing showing them with the
the brighter the red the higher than the
Leal frequency and what you can see is
very strong stripes associated with
individual tumors and if you go in and
look at say a region like this where you
get a whole band of sort of minor a low
low minor allele fraction across a range
of tumors these almost always are sort
of sequencing artifacts and and that you
know but it's a relatively rare
phenomena in the data set and you know
this is it blowin up of a few of these
things that look like they might be
shared mutations across individuals you
know here might be an example of 10 or
so mutations that are somehow clonally
related with the founding sells out of
the more than you know a couple thousand
mutations in that individual maybe
there's ten mutations or something that
we're foundational to the cells that
derive both of them and that's actually
not too hard to imagine from just a you
know early development kind of point of
view that suggests they're not really
independent they do have a consensual
relationship so that oh yeah this is
sort of what you mean by ancestral to me
right so obviously all cells in the body
came from an egg so so it's some set
it's some very strong definition and
definition vessel they have to be
ancestral right and so so i would i
would argue that if you know if it's if
these are real mutations which i'm not
even sure that they are then then we're
talking about on the order of eight
mutations out of a couple thousand right
so it is a very early split and and we
do see some evidence for mutate things
that look like mutations between tumor
and blood going away when we use match
kidney normal and so that could be
something funny about the sequencing of
the blood that we you know missed the
mr. rare variant and the blood and we
didn't and we couldn't filter it out or
it could be that they're the progenitors
of the kid
which I don't know exact number but it's
probably in the thousands or something
of primordial cells could contribute to
that right and so so you sort of expect
there to be mutations even that early in
development as you're putting up the
foundation so so I think I think we're
talking about minimal extremely minimal
early contribution but it's it but but
it's a pretty robust way of assessing
the this behavior so we obviously
started this because we thought there
might be back commonalities between
tumors of the same in the same
individual all right we you know there
was we we if we hadn't found anything
that was common between tumors and same
individual we've been very sad because
this this would have broken our our
fundamental hypotheses and so obviously
the first thing to do is just start
looking mutation frequencies and and we
can see quite strong biases highly
statistically significant biases in
which mutations are showing up in which
patients and so the strongest one here
is basically this individual f28 green
so 28 year old female who we've colored
green for all concordance in the in the
in the in the plots has nearly twice as
many t2g substitutions as anyone else in
the population is relatively rare
mutations overall but she's got a lot of
them relatively speaking you can see
there's some wide variations in this
blue patient here in the number of T 2
c's and you know see the t's which are
relatively common they're still
statistically significant variation
amongst amongst those so we're seeing
biases in the mutational spectrum at but
we don't know if this is environmental
or genetic it seems very plausible that
is either both and and you know I think
that's something we're fundamentally
interested in trying to examine don't
necessarily have great ideas on how to
do it but but open to suggestions um and
then pushing this a little further we've
tried to look at the mutation spectra
sort of the the things that Peter
Campbell and get it gets it published on
as well as many others where we take the
trinucleotide context we have actually
been very unsuccessful recapitulating
the published signatures for clear cell
kidney cancer in our data set we can see
trinuclear to contact biases in our data
set but they they don't correspond to
the published ones that are supposed to
be present in kidney cancer and so
I'm not sure if we don't know how to do
it we're morons or if there's
fundamental differences in the way we've
tackled this problem versus other groups
but but you can see quite quite strong
differences in for example the the sea
to AC the T spectrum here which there's
a set of tumors here to have higher
higher propensity for here's T to a and
c c 2 t mutations are higher in this
group and then here we have roughly c2g
mutations and then a very strong set of
tumors that have have T to see
substitutions in a wide variety of
context um and and so so there's clearly
bias across the distribution on and and
there is bias across individual you can
see all the patients who are yellow from
one individual are on the left side of
the standard gram the vast all the green
patients are on the right side of the
dendrogram and you know with with some
straight for some I actually don't know
the statistical method I didn't look it
up and pologize there's a p-value of
roughly 10-15 testing is a separate way
of checking this we're seeing a very
strong bias in the mutations that the
spectra that we see across the
individuals and how they're organized so
it looks to us like that as you might
expect either genetics or environment
it's plain is pretty substantial role in
the kinds of mutations that are showing
up in tumors during evolution but it but
we were really surprised that we didn't
see smoking because some of these
patients have a pretty substantial
smoking history and and we don't see
that but it is a known risk factor fork
for clear cell kidney cancer okay so
going back to the TCGA data and I showed
you the cut this is a plot of the copy
number where chromosomes are across the
x-axis here and and patient samples are
on the y on and and using a V we can
just ask are our individual chromosome
gained or lost and based on whatever I
told you you would expect to see 3p loss
and so here's 3p and you can see that
nearly all these patients have loss of
3p ninety-one percent of all that of all
the patient tumors have loss of 3p in
this data set okay you can see other
stereotypical behavior gain of five q
there
some reason to think that the 3p and 5qr
fuse together most often so there's a
mechanistic basis for this rearrangement
because you loss of 14 here right so
there's a stereotypical pattern but but
this loss on 3q sorry on 3p is is the
standard is the standard thing that
happens and it's also what happens in
hereditary cancers and obviously was
well known prior prior to prior to this
but when we looked at this we were
immediately struck by one specific
behavior that that this individual here
again the the sort of stand out f28
green individual in addition to the loss
on 3d which happens in all of her tumors
10 out of 13 tumors have lost 3q okay
and only one other individual or maybe
two other tumors his state is not very
good unfortunately for cut from copy
number for this individual for some
reason have lost 3q and if you go back
to the TCGA data you can see that loss
of 3p is standard loss of 3q is actually
relatively rare here we're sorting for
it and it's only about ten percent of
cases have lost 3 q's this is a
relatively rare phenomena in the data
set to lose 3q and yet here we have an
individual who's lost whole chromosome 3
10 out of 13 times and so the p-value
that is astronomically small there's a
very strong bias this as individual
behaving differently in terms of
chromosome loss and our first thing let
me she just throws chromosomes more
easily righty so you know whatever her
genetics or environment are is she's
losing chromosome them rapidly but you
just look at the rest of the genome and
there's no strength no increase in the
rate of chromosome lost anywhere else so
it's not something that simple right and
so we're sort of deeply trying to think
about mechanisms based on that that
would that would be biased towards loss
of a specific chromosome we've got a
bunch that we're trying to test but
haven't haven't [ __ ] anything
compelling yet and so so this bias here
could be genetic could be environmental
I think we favor genetics on this one
for a variety of reasons but but
remember this is this is always the same
chromosome that's being lost because the
one is inherit one has the inherited vhl
allele and so we're always losing the
other chromosome here um once you accept
this result and you go in and look
there's actually some pretty believable
other biases here we've got there's
three men
this this patient has lost chromosome y
and three out of six tumors which is a
relatively high rate not not enough
given all the multiple testing you have
to do to do do all this that that you
believe it but but seems to be a bias
there the the frequency of
rearrangements between 3p and fight re
doing yet between 3q + 5 q as estimated
by gain on 5q and loss of and retention
of a retention of 3p retention 3q looks
to be perhaps biased as well with this
individual showing showing it quite
frequently and so I think that there are
going to be with a bigger data set you'd
be able to see more biases and how and
in the chromosomal patterns that are
that are happening here and I think I
think the vast majority of those will
turn out to be genetic and so happy yeah
yeah I think a lot of times it happens
through the centromere so I think a lot
of times it's very difficult to pull out
our group has historically been very bad
at finding chromosomal fusion for
whatever reason so so we I think we'd be
more than happy to share the data to
someone who really thinks they're good
at it but but we have not been very
successful at in and I think because
it's typically near the centromere we
kind of if we didn't see it we couldn't
really be sure that it wasn't just for
you know hard to see so so I don't know
okay so so going back then to to our
initial question you know the easiest
explanation was for this behavior would
be simply that the the tumor that arose
out that had lost whole chromosome 3 was
a clone of some early thing right a very
early event lost whole chromosome 3 and
then all the tumors gross out of that we
you know we have and and so this is
looking at all the mutations that are
shared across individual across the
individual tumors here and if that were
true you would expect that the 10 tumors
that are in light green would share some
set of mutations that are excluded in
the dark green tumors on the outside
here right that that those would be
foundational mutations that that arose
very early in the lineage and because we
have whole genome data here that that
does not show
evidence of shared mutations we really
think these are independent losses
rather than then an early loss that
that's set up a field defect or
something like that and and the number
of mutations here that you you just
would expect to see you know one or two
or three or four mutations given how
many we have that are shared uniquely
amongst here and there's really no
evidence for it at all so I think the
vast majority these are probably
sequencing errors or something like that
it's without checking them all it's a
bit of a passel but um but there's
there's no reason to think that this is
an early event and so this is just
commenting on on the potentiality of
shared stuff okay so going back to what
we know from TCGA we've got the set of
driver genes that are listed there is on
the order of 10 or so and since since
the clear cell paper came out a bunch of
groups have looked for other driver
genes that are sort of pan pan pan
driver genes and so using a using the
the hundred and twenty ish so they're
published in the pan campaign paper we
wanted to ask you know what what's the
evidence for driver genes in these
tumors and and are we and are we saying
the same driver gene happing in the same
patient because that would be very
interesting right if the if the the
constrained genetics and environment
were pushing the same sort of found
driving lesions that would be a very
cool sort of constraint on tumor
evolution and and obviously we're really
hoping to see some effect like that and
and instead what we saw was really odd
to us that when we looked at the tumors
we call we call them we call a vhl a
driver because we have loss of
heterozygosity and effectively every one
of these tumors and we know they have
one bad defect so we know every one of
these tumors has it is loss of function
for vhl and so that ever every tumor
here gets a vhl mark just for just for
showing up and and the size of the tumor
in two dimensions is drawn to scale here
so these are you know this is like a
one's one and a half Center two
centimeter tumor here's a one centimeter
tumor for each of the different tumors
from all the different individuals um
and Chris Ricketts within with
with with marstons group then added some
knowledge about how aggressive these
tumors were based on pathological
grading ok so we in the lighter colors
we have grade 2 which was you know less
bad than grade 3 and what quickly hot
popped out at us is that the higher the
grade tumors they had a lot more driver
mutations to them and so this is looking
at the clear cell SMGs listed 16 here
the pan can SMG 114 and all tea all teas
you know any gene that was ever called
the driver in any tumor type 250 or so
and so you know this individual here
number one he's throwing he's developing
a lot more aggressive tumors relatively
speaking four out of five of his tumors
are grade 3 versus you know 13 out of 13
or grade 2 in this individual so there
is a patient-specific effect on grade
which is kind of interesting but there's
this corresponding effect on number of
drivers here ok and so these this to
these tumors have lots of driver
mutation seemingly versus you know the
vast majority of these things have vhl
and nothing else and so so that that was
really puzzling to me because you know I
was taught and we've shown people have
shown the slide that that tumors arise
because they have a hallmark set of
deregulated pathways and I've got tumors
here lots of them with vhl and nothing
else and we can't find anything else and
and that was really really I found it
surprising and it's not the first time
we've seen that but but these are pretty
pretty simple tumors relatively speaking
and so you know because we only did 40 X
genomes here you know there's a
possibility we've missed mutations right
but maybe maybe our mutation sensitivity
is only fifteen percent fifty percent or
something from 40 X genomes and so you
know maybe we really have drivers here
that we just didn't sequence properly
for whatever reason so Suzy went back
and picked 10 tumors that sort of spread
across grade individual um and the
number of nucleons level that were
available and we did exomes you know
reasonably deep exosomes 150 200 x
exomes so we were pretty sure that we
pick up extra mutations and when we did
that we actually found a
more drivers okay so so the the the
calls that were made in the genomes are
on top and the calls were made in the
exone they're on the bottom and so this
big big tumor here on the set six
centimeters or something went from
having nothing we could find other than
vhl to adding a couple very plausible
driver genes notch and nf1 and then
maybe SPM or something right so so the
the increased sequencing depth allowed
us to see extra mutations um and and
that was true in the vast majority of
cases here but you can see that the
grade threes didn't typically add more
mutations right so the grade threes when
we sequence them they had roughly the
same mutations as when we sequence them
later on so so this immediately
suggested to us that this was not a
sequencing depth problem but it has
something to do with biology what was
going on and as soon as you looked at
looked at whether or not these mutations
were clonal or not and it was very
obvious that there's a difference here
so on the left is just one tumor from
the 28 year old male um and and this is
very allele frequency corrected by
purity and copy number and you can see
that there are no predicted drivers in
the clonal fraction here but to the two
of the three of the drivers sorry that
that we see are showing up in the
subclone part okay so it looks to us
like the drivers here are all being are
all being contributed later in tumor
evolution whereas you look at the grade
3 this is a relatively low sexart so
it's a 65-percent tumor purity the the
single driver here which is in one of
the TCGA SMGs for clear cell is clonal
and so you know just sort of looking
through this pretty quickly here's
another independent tumor ah here's the
clonal fraction here are the sub clonal
fractions and again the drivers that we
expect to see are all sub clonal in
these individuals here's a grade 3
here's the grade 3 where the worst words
where it's a clonal driver here's
another grade 3 where there are three
plausible driver mutations that are
clonal a couple more that are right on
the shift to becoming clonal so they're
in the inflection point here's a grade 2
where this looks like there's one clonal
driver and one sub clonal driver and so
so I think what this means is that these
in the lint low-grade tumors have
acquired vhl and maybe not much else
right maybe all it takes to be a tumor
is vhl and some epigenetic rearrangement
right not a lot of not a lot of what we
call classic driver events that's one
interpretation of the data and I don't
think it's the only one and so so that
immediately brought us back to the
gerlinger paper that have been public
that people have talked about already
the meeting and and I want to highlight
one thing that no one knows no one's
reminded everyone about is that is that
one of the most compelling things about
this paper is that different parts of
the tumor have solved the evolutionary
bottleneck it with different mutations
right and so we have one two three set D
two mutations that are all as far as we
can tell independent and in different
cells right so that's its there are
different sites so they're not being
constrained by the butt but there the
tumor is solving this problem in three
different ways in different clones and
that's and that's quite striking and so
I think we need to pay attention to that
um and so this is a gerlinger paper on
sporadic cases this is a ten-centimeter
tumors there's a monster tumor that
they've looked at right and so there's a
lot of opportunities here for subclones
to grow out the the Swans group has also
looked at a few hereditary tumors from
von hippel-lindau cases not quite as in
depth and they report actually something
slightly different they don't see they
don't see the branch devolution that you
show here if I were they did not provide
a figure so I had to make one and I made
it really lame my apologies but but if
you took this multi region sequencing
approach that they drawn for this for
the vhl patient r 4 r 3 r 7 r 2 r 6 you
get a tree that look like this and they
call this linear revolution rather than
the branch devolution um and so so there
you know from review you can find you
can find examples like this where where
you've got cereal replacement of a
population as evolution goes forward
versus branched evolution where you have
different pockets of the tumor
or the store in turn or mixed
populations of the tumor all coexisting
at the same time and I'll be honest is
since i work on vhl syndrome I'm not
very happy about this resulted because
because I want vhl syndrome to be as
much like corrected or sporadic cases as
possible so so I found this little
problematic but i think i think our
observation about grades sort of implies
that maybe this is a little more subtle
and so we're rihanna we're in the
process of trying to reanalyze this
wanton data in a slightly different
context and i hope that we'll be able to
provide some deeper insight so i just
want to take take some of some of the
things we've seen and extrapolate them a
little bit about about what they mean
for evolution because I think sometimes
these principles get lost and and when
we see branched subclones there's a
there's a lot of possible reasons for
that and when we see linear evolution
there's a lot of possible reasons for
that and so so for example if you have
multiple subclones in a branch tree one
hypothesis is that they could be
spatially segregated over here is one
branch over here is another branch over
here is another branch if they're not
spatially segregated it has different
evolutionary implications but it doesn't
mean it doesn't mean that they're not
important things to take home and so so
one possibility is that these things are
happening late and the tumor is evolving
and then they're acquiring mutations and
they grow out another possibility is
that mutate mutations and different
compartments of the same tumor are
actually synergistic or codependent
right and so the what's really important
and saurabh touched on this is that the
fitness landscape is not constant right
that you can't just say that the this
initial tumor has these mutations and
his fitness as X and it's going to grow
on and forever grow at some fixed rate
that's almost certainly untrue right the
environment changes as a function of
time and because of that we you know
everyone needs to remember that that the
fitness of an organism or in this case
the cancer cell is dependent on its
environment with a change in environment
the fitness can radically change and so
so the the behavior of subclones is
highly dependent upon what you think the
fitness environment looks like and I
think this is a ripe area for study
don't have any great ways of tackling it
but for the most part we don't have ways
of measuring changes in Fitness over to
revolution other than the case where you
apply chemotherapy and everything
changes right where there you even know
what the fitness change was you can take
away the fitness change and see if
things river back and so I think there's
some things to pay attention to here and
and so this this linear model which
we've seen in things like AML where you
get cereal replacement of the population
is usually under a constraint where
you've got it exhaustion is selective
force that you've applied right and and
it's it's less clear on whether or not
the the linear model that that swans
reporting vhl syndrome act actually
makes sense front from from the from a
biological possibility it's possible it
is possible that the tumors grow a
little faster and differences in the
initial fitness population could a lot
could favor certain differential
behaviors and I just want to know one
should know one showing something like
this so I think it I think it could be
instructive that um you know if you've
got a centimeter tumor and you have the
sort of a typical model would be three
new mutations per cell division that has
one and a half billion mutations in it
right so an enormous possibility of all
the mutations are that are allowed in
the human genome have already happened
in that tumor and as you get bigger and
bigger the number of cells is is is
rising with the cube you get huge
numbers of potential mutations showing
up so um you know if you think about
number of ways to make a null mutation
in set d2 when is the likelihood that
there are multiple set d two mutations
in a population of a million cells 10
million cells or 100 million cells and
actually I think somewhere around 10 to
100 million cells there's there's an
inflection point we actually expect
multiple secti two mutations and if they
have even a transitory rapidly different
fitness fitness behavior they could
rapidly take over
to at least go compete in the population
their fitness might flow down later on
but but I think this is something that
we need to pay attention to and and you
know I could draw much smaller tumors in
this but but we have enormous tumors of
with enormous genetic complexity going
on and so I don't find it too surprising
that we have genetic selection for for
subclones because of the of the
diversity so so I more or less cover
this but but I did want to sort of
question whether or not there's even a
difference between linear and branched
devolution linear and branched evolution
and you know they're sort of positive as
being different things but I'm not sure
they really are i think they're
different I think there are different
views of different constraints on the
same system right it's all evolution so
so so I'm not sure what take over but
like I said we are looking in the vhl
data exome data from swanton to see if
we see for example subclones and and the
additionally the evidence so far we are
seeing a lot more subclones and then
then were reported in in that paper okay
so in my five minutes I wanted to get to
sort of the last question of why do
these tumors have such few drivers I
mean I told you all about these Cerreta
Terry clear clear cell renal cell
carcinomas that have on average one
driving mutation that we can are smart
enough to identify and and if you look
in the TCGA data here's the TCGA data
twenty percent of the tumors there which
are mostly grade three tumors have no
drivers that were smart enough to
identify right things that look like we
understand what's going on um and and it
gets worse for some tumors so here's
here's data from papillary kidney that
we published that just came out a month
this month I get her last month and and
this is looking at type 1 and type 2
this is the copy number profile there's
there's a very large this is this is
patients on the y-axis here genome on
the X you can see that a lot of these
patients here have a very stereotypical
chromosome single copy chromosome gain
pattern as a geneticist I want you know
point mutation in Raths or you know some
some really obvious strong drive
or gain of chromosome 3 is a very
uncompelled gain of chromosome 7 sorry
is it is a pretty uncompelled driver to
me really that's like that's the best
you can tell me about what's making this
a tumors it has gained of chromosome 7
and anum papillary with a reasonable
number of cases 200 or 180 or something
there's there's a relatively small
number of drivers it's although it's
about the same as sorry hundred fifty
seven but their frequency of mutation is
very low okay and if you and if you then
go and look for cases that have no
drivers in papillary it's huge in almost
half of the type 1 tumors that we
sequenced have nothing other than
chromosome 7 gain that we can really
believe as as a driver and you know if
the either we're going to be really good
about understanding how chromosome 7
game drives papillary kidney cancer or
we're missing a lot here and so I think
we have a big challenge in a bunch of
tumors particularly they're relatively
indolent early tumors which both clear
cell renal cell carcinoma and papillary
start out off as and and so you know
these are very good outcome tumors but
and we call them cancers and they look
like answers two pathologists but they
don't have drivers which is I find
unsatisfying so I think I think it's a
big challenge to to the computational
group is to figure out what the hell's
going on in here alright and so on ty
more or less I will stop there and so
Susie Fay and my group in Asia Mitchell
did the vast majority work Katie's
Katie's the one who actually got us the
samples which took you know that when I
said it took us seven years took us like
four years to get samples working with
the federal government and then and then
Marston and caffeine and Chris at NCI so
and then the whole tcj teams thank
Road I just say this broad versus video
evolution right uh-huh are the sporadic
too much more aggressive than the
Heritage Areas there they tend to be but
they also tend to be found much later
right so so the hereditary tumors we
find because we're looking for them and
and the sporadic ones we find because
you have a clinical problem you can't
blood in your urine or something right
this curious because we saw an ovarian
cancer when a small sample size that a
very strongly branch evolutionary
trajectory typically associated with
poor survival and and lower lower sub
Evelyn so this is high-grade serous
ovarian cancer yeah I mean so the
outcomes in their ovarian are so awful
i'm not sure what to do about that right
but i believe it I really do believe it
i think that and there's a fair there's
a fair bit of evidence that more genetic
complexity is a bad prognostic feature
but but particularly the high-grade
serous ovarian cancers have such a nasty
outcome that i'm not sure what to do
about it exactly but yeah i was just
wondering if there's any do any data for
it between the linea and branched or
look like i said i don't think it's a
real distinction I mean I think I think
I think I think whole evolution right
and like you said it's kind of the same
underlying process but then dif
different selection pressures maybe
you're different more clonal expansion
on one side or no there are different
aspects of the same thing of course but
that doesn't mean they're not different
in clinical use yeah I think it has to
do with selective pressure right that
that that um that you'll get a branched
architecture under certain selective
kinds of pressures and under certain
population sizes and you'll get a linear
model when the population size are
really small for example right if or or
when there is you know so so there's a
fair amount of literature on the idea of
clonal expansion without def right so if
you have death associated with with the
behavior and you're removing cells from
a population you could get things that
look much more linear than then if if
there's a if there's not if right of
things don't actually go away they just
peter out right that look that those
will look very different than so
I think I think it has to do with the
kind of selective pressures that are
going on but my biases for clear-cell
it's it's all going to be branched when
we when we get down into it but but I
think in other cases where you have a
very strong selective pressure that they
can remove things from the population
then you get this linear behavior I mean
for your estimates of how many mutations
are in these tumors or six centimeters
yeah wild expected are you assuming the
cells you're seeing are the ones that
were produced during the growth of the
tumor right and because that was that
sure it could be even higher yeah
absolutely true ya know whether death
occurs during the growth of those tumors
or seems to be like a really important
question for evolution it's almost
certainly tumor dependent um there
there's a i think a reasonable as
evidence that some tumors for example
have higher rates of chromosome miss
segregation right their genomes are more
aberrant as a result they're more likely
to throw throw off chromosomal genotypes
in their daughters that are not what
parental genotypes were um and that the
fitness of those aberrant genomes is
much much lower so whether or not they
die versus just stop growing I don't
know how to answer right but but it
certainly wouldn't be the case that you
would expect that the the effective
fitness of a cell of all of its
daughters is equal to the parent right
which is which is a slightly different
way of looking at death and I'm not sure
how that would play out exactly but you
know if if if if two daughters is l1 has
a fitness you know the the parent has a
fitness of 11 daughter as a fitness of
one the other daughter could have a
fitness 20 right and even though it
never divides again it never propagates
again so it doesn't contribute so so in
that case the number of cells would
effectively be the wouldn't actually
matter that that hadn't happened so it
would only matter if there was death and
I think in some tumors there will be in
others there won't be but I don't have
good number
yeah you're a green patient with
chromosome 6 the tire coming 33 yeah so
I didn't quite follow the argument for
why so so if they were dependent right
if they happen early in tumor evolution
then we would expect to see some set of
mutations that happened in the lineage
of those early cells and unless it was
the very first cell of the kidney or
something like that before any mutations
have shown up we would expect to see a
shared said mutations in those tumors
that all had chromosome 3 loss and not
in the ones that didn't have chromosome
3 loss right we expect some number of
mutations we can't prove that it's not
the earliest thing we can measure but
because we don't see a set of mutations
that are explicitly shared we take that
as as you know from from our work on
timing we would say this is the earliest
point one percent of all events that
could have happened right so we so
ruling it out explicitly is impossible
but making a statistical argument about
when it would have had to occur I think
it's pretty compelling it's thick or
again thank you